Matt Damon's father Kent has died a rep  for Matt confirmed to ET his dad  Kent Damon died on December 14th after a  long battle with cancer he was 74  according to the Boston Globe Kent died  of multiple myeloma a rare blood disease  after his condition worsened in recent  months Matt first revealed his father  was diagnosed with myeloma at a benefit  for Massachusetts General Hospital in  2011 and since his father was diagnosed  Matt has helped raise awareness and  funds for cancer research and treatment  the sad news of his father's death comes  after Damon recently pulled out of  several scheduled public appearances  including the Los Angeles premiere for  his new film downsizing you see on every  side  [Music]